je ne cacherai pas que je suis
excessivement préoccupé par le fait
qu'on serve relâchement avec le des
confidents relâchement et c'est sur
c'est l'été il fait beau on a été
confiné mais pour moi c'est
excessivement important si on veut
éviter soit que cette version comme ans
ou qu'on se fasse face à une deuxième
vague à ce que tous les québécois
respecte la distanciation deux mètres
que s'il qu'ils fassent l'étiquette
respiratoire qu'il porte un couvre
visage et du gène des mains avec nous ce
soir peter sergakis le président de
l'union des tenanciers de bars du québec
monsieur sur gars caisse bonsoir bonsoir
mesure alors les bars peuvent rouvrir
mais les gens doivent rester assis
qu'est ce que vous pensez de signal je
pense que le docteur il va pas souvent
d'un barbet est-ce que vas tu as et les
clients sur une 16
je pense que si on suivait les consignes
de santé publique
il peut rester debout ainsi pied d'un à
l'autre donc je verrais pas pourquoi que
les clients sont obligés à 6016 six
pieds plus loin
mais est ce que ça peut fonctionner
quand on vous dit on peut rouvrir les
bars aujourd'hui les gens doivent rester
assis est ce que vous vous êtes parfait
on va rouvrir les bars et on va faire ça
m'ait coûté aux envois dans un bar pour
avoir du plaisir
nous avons des bars et ce qu'est la
santé publique c'est d'abord temps puis
les antilles de nogent bleui c'est
important aussi là mais c'est pas ça que
les derniers mois on demande le
gouvernement de nous donner les ovations
même en donner foucault ou là on va
ouvrir avec 15 20 projets nasale ans
d'âge on est beaux touriste
on n'est pas de vaccin on n'est pas le
médicament tout sur ses comptes
notre commerce jeu parce que on est
laissé libre par la dernière partout au
québec
s'il serait pas facile il va voir
beaucoup de faillites foucault commence
pour voir comment ça vous analyse mais
ici on pense les futures c'est beau ben
ouais le vous êtes 15 20 % de capacité
ça va être ça peu près non mais quelle
salade à ce qu'un oui masquer la
créatrice et rebelote une partie des
clientèles qui viendrait pas parce
qu'ils ont peur puis leur passé c'est
l'été d'un centre-ville de montréal 72
ans élu touriste on n'est pas aucune
touriste don kelly le coup il me dit
mais c'est pas moi qui va y aller avant
ma volée si quelqu'un lors d'y aller
d'un débat je propose change on n'est
pas de vaccin on n'est pas de
médicaments c'est là mais on oublie
quand même là mais il va voir les
failles et après après l'autre les
moniales elle est en acier va livrer
pour tester pour voir ça fonctionne
puis sinon il va vérifier par tous
partout à trois risques avec vous vous
avez une quarantaine de bars et
restaurants oui est ce que vous allez
ouvrir l'ensemble de vos installations
11,1 présente on est les problèmes avec
l'épicier du gouvernement fédéral avant
tout les abris yves bot venus travailler
parce que on va lui donner la temps
partiel pour commencer les abris 10 b je
viens de repos dessus et dans tout les
excuses je normal
vous avez deux mille pièces par mois
c'est beaucoup d'argent
vous pouvez pas payer plus que sa mère
au pays on arriverait polonais les
dépenses vous connaisez de la bière est
la boisson vous coupez les loyers
d'actrice telle assurance 3000 droit moi
et me fermer
c'est on n'arrive pas ce modèle
d'affaires là qu'on vous propose à
partir d'aujourd'hui et ce qui peut
durer longtemps
pas trop longtemps un mois deux mois
maximum et arrive quoi au bout de deux
mois vous vous attendez à quoi plus tard
cet été
60 % de foyers dans les bars au québec
oui on attend on attend quand vous avez
loto-québec pour ouvrir les vidéos
qu'aucun aussi le basket casino et
vauvert et ont donné le mandat à loto
québec on va voir des mecs est ce que
les casinos il faut les casinos mai loto
québec yves rausis une imaginaire vidéo
poker parce que beaucoup d'énergie et de
temps aux machines naturellement
vraiment les mots niveau se diversifier
avec les avec l'imaginent puis j'oublie
pause les temps puis on a besoin est
revenu là aussi le dock est notre avenir
ses proches c'est pas bien
est ce que il y en a beaucoup à ce
moment depuis trois mois trois mois et
demi qui ont décidé de ne pas ouvrir
déjà ou qui ont carrément déclaré
faillite y en a beaucoup qui ont décidé
des pauvres y en a beaucoup qui ont
déclaré faillite usé mais la majorité
est un espoir qui est un ouvrage il vaut
cas pas récupéré qu'est-ce qui ont
dépassé qu est ce qu ont paru les trois
mois et demi puis vaut payer les dettes
qu'ils ont accumulés mais ils vont
trouver les temps plusieurs parce
qu'elle n'est pas y voyait de l'or
la salade à 6 aurait pu là que les
touristes rébus leur way est ce que vous
avez réfléchi à l'avenir de vos
installations de vos barres est ce que
vous vous êtes dit il faut que je
réinvente mon modèle d'affaires à partir
de maintenant les modèles de futures
c'est les petits établissements de
mètres de distance entre chacun pour
chaque personne ça va être tout chaque
table ça va être un peu compliqué quand
maintenant mais je parle pour la future
la baballe et lille bruxelles mois
l'homme
donnée n'est ce pas quel est le problème
des verrues ça va être réglé
si cette règle ils oublient lol mais
nous ça nous prend les subventions du
gouvernement
québec y est bon et du beaucoup lu le
dernier bar on est de la halde
aujourd'hui êtes un duo nouvelle on va
aider l d'eau parce que ces compagnies
québécois chic du salé on va l'aider
parce que les bureaux servi et un au
québec mais les marches il y restera il
emploie 320 pour trois cent mille
employés directs emploi puis un autre
5000 indirecte les fournisseurs puis
tout ça parce que les gouvernements du
québec est venu l'essai moore et puis
pense qu'un homme qui va prendre
l'établissement seulement pour les
loyers puis tranquillement et va ouvrir
je comprends pas pourquoi le rhône et la
majorité ok - exane et 40 établissements
quand même là mais la majorité les
terrassiers la celi piti piti l image
d'entreprise et ont travaillé les
dizaines d'années franc fort pour
établir un petit commerce puis là on
lisait de poissy le je vous dis le c'est
à port les fédérales c'est sûr qu'elle
ait fait des rallyes la subvention
salariale notamment les séries oui c'est
vrai mais québec et nous est pas donné
grand chose
donc moi moi et prétend qu'elle est en
fait les idées des hommes
le gouvernement du québec on va le
laisser mourir puis keynote il va
prendre les espaces avec un autre modèle
mais c'est triste
on n'est pas content le hockey le
message est lancé en tout cas clairement
messieurs sergakis merci beaucoup bonne
chance c'est un peu blasé